[Music]
welcome to the week in 60 minutes
brought to you by spectator tv recorded
on thursday april the 15th on this
week's show we'll cover everything from
climate change to covert to lobby
i'll be speaking to stanley johnson
about the government's ambitious green
plans
and to christopher mayer about how good
a foreign policy
the whole global warming approach of the
government is
and just how many lobbyists does the
failed financier
lex greensell have in whitehall who
knows
anyway all that to come in the next hour
of public service tv
at its finest now if you enjoy what we
do here at spectator tv why not take out
a subscription
to the spectator magazine it's the
fastest growing current affairs
publication in europe and within its
pages and
on our website you can read all your
favorite spectator
tv contributors we'll even throw in a 20
pound
amazon gift voucher all for free if you
sign up at spectator dot co
dot uk slash tv offer or just google
spectator tv
that's a subscription of 12 issues for
12 pounds
plus a free 20 pound amazon voucher
do the arithmetic it's a no-brainer and
as ever a very special thanks to charles
stanley for their continued support of
the week in 60 minutes
charles stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms
one of the oldest companies on the
london stock exchange
we're delighted that their partners with
us in this venture
now david cameron there's a name you
didn't think you'd hear much about ever
again
but in recent weeks the former prime
minister has dominated the news agenda
for his somewhat cack-handed attempts to
generate
more pocket money for himself by
lobbying on behalf of a financier
called lex grinsell this week new
revelations emerged that a senior civil
servant
was employed by both green sill and the
cabinet office
that's right by greenville and the
cabinet office
the cabinet office which is at the heart
of government the johnson government has
announced an inquiry
into the whole affair but has blocked a
parliamentary inquiry
so how many more skeletons are in the
lobby closet
i'm joined now by our deputy political
editor katie balls
and uh by joe rutter she's a senior
research fellow at the think tank
uk in a changing europe she's a former
civil
servant katie this story seems to be
developing
uh now i'm broadening out
not just uh from david cameron
but to the whole way the core of
whitehall
seems to conduct its business with
lobbyists give us the background
yes it rather than dying out is actually
ramping up and
i think that we had a situation you know
a couple of weeks ago where it was more
an embarrassing story of david
david cameron now that's still the case
we've had a photo this week of his uh
camp out in the desert and he was trying
to charm
uh saudi prince um more glamping
but ultimately now i think in terms of
westminster we've gone from
questions from ministers to widespread
is this an institutional issue now
rishi sunak is someone who's seen that
as though they need to answer questions
as is matt hancock you had a drink with
david cameron over the green source saga
but as you mentioned in your
introduction we also now have the
arrival of civil servants on the scene
bill crawford someone who was in the
cabinet office as an official but also
at the same time briefly
working for greenslaw now i think that
uh moving this to the civil service as
well
uh has seen a letter from simon case uh
the top civil servant ultimately
uh asking everyone to come forward in
terms of permanent secretaries and
say now if there are any such conflicts
of interest in their departments on
civil servants
because while you have a situation where
mps and also journalists who work in
parliament have to register their
interests
there isn't such a thing for civil
servants and there is a sense that this
could go much deeper
in terms of whether the prime minister
is on this so far i think the pressure
seems to be more on a
his cabinet and now uh civil servants
than himself but
we're already seeing how he uh wage war
on lobbying
as a politician it could come back to
bite you with reports about
his interactions with the saudi arabia
prince
jill some of us were not entirely
surprised that david cameron was
lobbying on behalf of
interests that were paying him it
happens that we were a bit surprised
how useless he seemed to be at it what
has surprised
i think everybody including myself is
this idea that you can be a civil
servant at the heart of
government and also working for somebody
in the private sector which i believe is
what this civil servant bill cruthers
has been doing that must have surprised
you too
yeah it surprised me a lot and i was
getting emails from
former senior civil servants saying
don't think this happened in my time
uh the defense from the cabinet office
that this was not uncommon
i think most people found very very
surprising and that's of course what
we'll see is a response to this simon
case initiative
to actually ask i think if it reveals
that there's a lot of this going on
then i think uh lots of questions will
be asked um
i mean you know bill crothers obviously
quite an interesting appointment himself
came in from the private sector he'd
been a long-standing partner
one of the big consultancy firms not
arguably a man
who would be in need of a bit of private
sector experience i mean in some cases
uh civil servants are encouraged to take
up positions as non-executive directors
or charity trustees and things like that
to give them a bit of exposure
we have some comments programs because
generally thought
that you don't want civil servants who
basically never left their government
department building get a bit of a clue
of what's going on in the real world
um but the fact that somebody with loads
of private sector experience
did this and did this in a way that then
allowed him to smooth a very easy
transition
once he left without having to go
through any of the
checks the pre-feeble checks that we
have in place
uh looks even more bizarre i mean you
say that
and it came from one of his emails i
think that uh bill crothers said that
his arrangements are not
uncommon in the civil service service
i mean that's news to me uh it seems
like it's news to you
uh as well if it's not uncommon
do we know when it started because i
don't think it's it's
always been part of the white hole
firmament
so i think there may have been occasions
when
you had people say where the family ran
a business
and they had some direct ship of some
sort of smallish company and things like
that that they would have
should have said is it okay if i go on
doing this or whatever
i think actually the biggest exception
that we've seen
is with a man who probably signed off
the cruthers appointment as okay
which was john manzoni if you remember
john manzoni he was recruited in from bp
first to run a thing called major
projects authority regarded as quite a
big catch to get somebody
who'd been quite a big beast in the
corporate world uh albeit with a rather
tarnished reputation
by the time he rocked up in government
uh to come and run that and then he
moved to be what was called chief
executive of the civil service so and
permanent secretary at the cabinet
office
and there's a big argument about whether
he could hold on
to a non-executive directorship he had
at s.a.b
miller as south african brewery now
people seem to be relaxed about that
while he was doing the major projects
authority because you could argue the
government's not going to ask a big
south african brewing company to build
a major piece of infrastructure or do a
big new it refit
sort of thing that the npa looked at but
then he
was you know forced after a bit of an
outcry to stand down from that
when he became there so he might have
thought it was much more normal practice
than the rest of us do but i mean that's
the really interesting thing as katie is
mentioning
when we see those answers to simon case
letter
does that defense hold up for a second i
think a lot of people at the top of the
civil service be seriously surprised
if the not uncommon defense uh holds
water because
i think it's a very rare rare event
though of course
loads of ex-civil servants do go on
the most senior ranks to a mass array of
board appointments that's slightly
regarded as a sort of
way of securing their lifetime income i
you know force for swore a bit of the
income i'd have got as a partner in a
big consultancy firm big law firm
uh left with my nice pension but i will
now supplement my retirement
with a bit of uh a few board
appointments
and actually the former permanent
secretary of the foreign office simon
fraser
went on to set up his own lobbying
company something called think global
and he's been
attracting quite a lot of uh former
civil service talent
to swell his ranks
katie when this story first emerged
around david cameron it
it sort of struck me that this was a
what the americans would call it inside
the beltway story
but it may no longer be that as it's
grown and grown and grown are there
signs that it's having
political cut through to the country
to the wider country well as you say i
think
i mean it's early days in terms of
engaging that but certainly labor
believe it is a story that will have cut
through and you saw kids stammer at
pmq's this week
really quite uh comfortable in one of
his more assured performances after
quite a tricky period for him uh where
he was going on the attack and quite
clearly wants to make it a tory sleaze
scandal
and i think that we have seen you know
with previous conservative governments
that
actually if there is a pattern if there
is a narrative um if you can get people
to associate what can be quite a tacky
story in terms of who did what and when
um then i think that you get to a
situation where
it could start to dent them if it does
look as though you know uh
politicians looking out for each other
it's an inside game
i think what would be interesting is
almost if this is completely
institutional
if uh and it does right i think to be
skeptical but if the bill proves defense
holds up that actually
is common at least during this period to
have you know multiple jobs as a civil
servant some
with conflicts of interest then it i
think it moves away from being a
as conservative specific scandal and
but again i think there is skepticism
that that is going to be the case
and we also have multiple inquiries so
you see the prime minister almost
wanting to put clear blue water between
himself
and what's happened to say that he takes
a strong stance but
i think it is damaging to the party as a
whole despite that
jill some people might say
that what david cameron attempted to do
was inappropriate
he was a misuse of his position
as a former prime minister in the way he
lobbied for something in which
he had a clear commercial stake
but in the end he didn't get anywhere in
the end what he wanted to happen didn't
happen
he uh was brushed off pushed back and so
in the end
perhaps the system worked what would you
say to that
the system seems to have worked i think
you know when we get to the results of
all these inquiries that katie
mentions we'll see whether they did do
that there are some
aspects clearly of the government loan
schemes that green sill did seem to be
able to access or at least it's uh
its clients uh with the liberty steel
collapse and things like that so we'll
see whether he was really as hopeless a
lobbyist
as it looks but actually you know the
mere fact
that uh he's taking up a lot of sort of
public time
and money look at all those meetings he
got one of labour's lines of attack
was this was time when the chancellor
was saying he didn't have time to meet
people like the self-employed who felt
they were very hard done by missed out
but he was racking up a lot of meetings
he or his senior officials with the
green sill guys
you know this was a time when people
were focusing a lot on designing schemes
to help out the whole economy
did it actually lead to people having to
waste quite a lot of time money and
effort
just to try and you know assure the
chance that really they had explored
every angle of this scheme that david
cameron was pushing
so even if it came to nothing you could
say that it wasted quite a bit of time
attention and effort uh in whitehall and
actually
you could say that you know what did
this do ministers being pushed
officials it takes actually quite robust
officials to say no
treasury officials are quite good at
that uh other departments
may not be actually so resistant when
ministers come
threatening shortcuts might be looking
at that remember this is all the time
of dominic cummings hard reign bunch of
sort of yeah hopeless civil servant
stick to the rules too bureaucratic by
half
let's just replace them pop them on the
head
and replace them with people who might
actually adopt a more fleet of foot
and responsive approach so actually some
people might have thought well if i
you know my minister is telling me not
david cameron but if my minister's
saying i'm quite keen on this cameron
scheme why are we saying no
they might actually at the end of the
day cave in
so i don't think we can take the fact
that he was resisted this time as
evidence that everything is hunky-dory
kta will almost certainly end up with
new rules governing lobbying when these
inquiries are done
and when we learn more about mr
cameron's behavior and
how green silver somehow managed to
insert himself into the heart of
government
uh as well that that's clear that there
will be some
tougher rules i think but i think i
would suggest katie that what's even
more clear
is that david cameron's reputation will
never recover
i i agree and i think that
i mean i think uh in spectator
publications you
rarely hear too much praise for theresa
may um but i think this is one area
where actually
uh the former prime minister comes out
much better than david cameron and some
others here
just in the sense that david cameron
used to talk about how it's important
that politicians
stuck around after front bench careers
after being prime minister in the
commons
it added to the way to the debate and
people shouldn't you know just shoot off
and
then obviously when push came to shove
that's exactly what he did
i think people were already quite
skeptical and questioning
of his words and what he did and i think
that you add to this this uh
lobbying scandal now i think it is
affecting david cameron's legacy in a
very negative way and it was already
pretty negative okay we'll leave it
there joe rutter thanks for joining us
uh on the spectator tv you know that
we'll be coming back to this subject
katie you have to stay with us
because you've done the cover story uh
for the spectator this week it's on
what's called cop26 it is the big
uh climate change uh global summit it
was meant to take place in glasgow
uh last november covert stopped that the
government hopes it can do so
again this november we shouted it for
them though that is
by no means certain the one thing is
clear katie is that
although it's not clear of anybody else
yet is going to turn up the british
government itself
is putting a lot of store by this uh
glasgow summit
yes uh i think climate summit 12-day
negotiations
you know over 100 nations and powers
coming together doesn't really scream
crowd pleaser
but in government this is being seen as
a big moment for boris johnson his
reset moment uh bruising few years
uh yes in terms of the pandemic but also
brexit
and i think cop 26 uh might not roll off
the tongue but it's ultimately that
moment where
they will try and uh forge their
post-pandemic agenda
uh by uh uniting the the world but also
the nation
uh the british public in a green frenzy
of environmentalism i mean if the plan
goes to plan
when i read your cover story katie it's
not clear to me
whether the the reason for the
enthusiasm
in whitehall for this is because they
want a
a wonderful game-changing uh climate
change summit in glasgow
or whether it's all part of boris
johnson's pro-brexit relaunch
which is more important i mean i think
it depends who you speak to
i think that when you look at the
climate summit it clearly ties with the
uk's international aims we recently had
the integrated review
and actually climate change and uh
biodiversity were
put as our number one international aim
so
it is a large part front and center also
of our foreign policy
and i think that when you look at boris
johnson trying to cozy up with joe biden
cop 26 is seen as a good way to do that
because the uk is hosting
but also the environment of the gender
is where i think the uk government
believe they will have the most
common ground because the us is also
pushing very hard on this
um but then i think where you get to
this domestic audiences
we have seen you know a few months ago a
departure of vote leave aids from
downing street
and i think that at the time some we
said in the magazines that this was the
beginning of a reshaping a new tone to
boris johnson's government
i think that is starting to come to
fruition and
newer aids i think uh new johnson allies
really think that you have to expand the
tory coalition
and they think that the past years have
been quite divisive for the country
and they think that the climate agenda
is how that you are
going to do that so i think there is an
international aim here but very much
there is a domestic one
and that is uh something that really
animates both the prime minister and and
those around him
let me bring in christopher mayer the
former british ambassador to washington
he's been listening to you katie
follows these things christopher what do
you make of of this it seems that this
summit
is now as much to do with the
johnson foreign policy as it is with
climate change well you know foreign
policy and the environmentalism
are completely intertwined in this
conference as they were back in 2015
when we had the paris
the famous or notorious paris climate
change
conference um and i read kate andrews uh
article the extreme interest because
if this is the way downing streets are
approaching the glasgow conference in
november
they have to be very careful they're not
heading for a fall
because the answer but what everybody
will want from this conference is a
quote unquote success but success
does not lie in the hands of the british
government even if it is the host for
the conference
the most important thing happening for
the glasgow conference as we speak
andrew i think is that john kerry
appointed by president biden to be the
senior
person uh on climate change is today
in beijing talking to the chinese
um about the environments and the
upcoming conference
because why china by a margin by a big
margin and the united states a lesser
margin
are the world's two biggest polluters
and therefore have to do more to achieve
the objectives of this conference
than anybody else that is where the
answer lies
and it will be either a skillful british
government
or a failed british government that
manages to act as honest broker between
these two
super polluters should just point out
i'd say
uh katie balls who wrote the article
this week uh not kid andrews um
we've got lots of duties thank you i
always get my case muddled up
apologies let me go to
let me go to katie balls i mean what uh
christopher says of course is quite
right china and america between them
account for almost
uh 50 of uh co2 emissions china now
a lot more in absolute terms learning
america
just one thing kitty do we have any
indication yet as to whether america
and or china are coming to glasgow
well it all uh relies on covid so while
uh
we know that the us government is very
keen to take part in this and i think
that
the behind the scene works that um
christopher touches on in the sense of
john kerry
um also working with alex sharma who's
the minister in charge of this summit
but i think
john kerry has definitely seen to hold
more weight when it comes to certain
uh international discussions and they do
want to be a role but
ultimately there's some talk of where
this summit's going to have to be
virtual
now the uk government is pushing really
hard against this i think partly because
they think in terms of this quite
complex negotiation it's better to have
people in a room than on zoom
but also because they think it's an
important event to show they're leading
physically but
if i think uh covert does not go in the
way that people want in terms of the
easing of the pandemic
you could have a situation where uh
certain countries do not turn up and on
china i think
that is obviously going to be the
hardest sell and it's already causing
ripples in the tory party because
we have a hawkish tory party that wants
the hardest dance on
china but yet in order to get this
agreement
and there is a sense that you are going
to have to
if you don't get china to do one thing
for you they will perhaps
expect you to offer concessions and
other things everything is intertwined
here
christopher if if it can't take place as
a
summit as we we used to know them and
has been done in zoom
that doesn't have the same political
impact i mean i can see how mr johnson
would like to be welcoming the chinese
president and the american president and
everybody else uh
to the the fair city of glasgow and be
seen to be the ringmaster
for a brief period that doesn't really
come across on zoom does it he doesn't
get the political follow
from a zoom conference no he doesn't but
andre it may be a blessing
in disguise because having
looking at katie balls getting the right
katie yeah well uh a account
it does seem to be that right now
darling street is heading for a fall
because supposing you have this thing
physically but supposing kovit allows it
and
everybody over 190 delegations decide to
turn up
you're gonna have around the glasgow
center as howling mob of extinction
rebellion
putting pressure on the delegates
because they regard they the extinction
rebellion regard
the paris conference five years ago six
years ago now
as a failure and so what the
uh the thousands and thousands of
members who support the greater tundberg
on this want is
an improvement now this may be
very hard to handle physically
it's not going to help having um
sturgeon lurking in the background
determined that this will not be a
success on scottish soil for a
for a british prime minister in the
shape of boris johnson so i can see
a virtual meeting maybe with fewer
member states taking part making it
easier
to arrive at an accommodation which can
be seen to be
an improvement on paris because i
thought the most terrifying thing in
in your article katie was where you said
something like
in downing street there was a view to
have everybody in the room will make a
new
agreement easier i can tell you having
everybody in the room will make them
getting an agreement infinitely more
difficult and if you look at the
successful conferences
um in recent years and indeed going back
to the congress of vienna 1814
1815 these are conferences which
either officially or unofficially choose
an
inner sanctum of four or five leading
member states
who broker an agreement between them
with the help of the british one hopes
this
time in real or virtual glasgow uh which
is then accepted by the rest of the
membership
um of of the conference that may be
easier to achieve
virtually than in reality it's very
interesting because i haven't
really thought of that though it does
deny as the
interest of seeing extinction rebellion
come up against the glasgow police
um but that may just be a
a sideshow but i would warn them that
i'm not sure they know what's
happen uh katie how did tory's taking to
this
new climate change johnson uh the the
man that when david cameron said
vote glue uh go green i think
wrote quite a few editorials um
in a magazine called the spectator which
he edited disparaging
all of that yes i think i mean
the conversion of boris johnson to uh
you know keen environmentalist
and now uh anyone in dynasty will say
this is the subject he is the most
enthusiastic about in meetings
uh the most keen um i think as we met
with skepticism in some parts of the
party
um lots of people put it down to his
family his fiancee
the people he hangs out with more now as
many of him are keen environmentalists
but i think there is still quite a lot
of enthusiasm in the tory party for a
few reasons
one the government keeps talking about
green jobs so
the website conservative homes as they
are just besieged with tory mps
desperate to write about green jobs
hoping someone i presume will come to
their constituency
two is very in vogue obviously in terms
of number 10 so if you are an
environmentalist you perhaps
will fare well in this government but
free i think that it does tap into a
wider enthusiasm in the public
on green issues and the environment
which i think
uh in all polling suggests has risen in
recent years
but i think where there is a potential
problem for this government is that
yes lots of people if you do a poll say
oh no i really care about the planet we
need to save the planet and i think that
is
countrywide that there's very similar
polling whether you're in a town or a
city on that or you know village
but when you get to the trickier
questions which is we have a net zero
target
2050 and how do you feel about
a ban on gas boilers how do you feel
about having to potentially get an
electric car in you know under 10 years
or you know 15 years and that's when
actually you get a lot more resistance
and therefore
i think that it's not very fashionable
at the moment in the tory party to raise
those concerns i think steve baker will
do it which normally suggests it's an
unpopular cause if
if he's having to be the chief rebel um
but it
but i think there is a creeping concern
amongst some of the red red wall mps so
the 2019
intake that perhaps the trade-offs here
in pushing this green agenda are not
being uh presented and as a reality
which is that
ultimately there is going to be a cost
to this and who is going to pay for it
final question to you uh christopher on
this it would seem from what you said
earlier whether it's a an actual summit
or a zoom
a virtual summit unless in the lead up
to it
that there is the outline of an
agreement between america and china
above all
unless a sort of building it doesn't
have to be signed sealed and delivered
before the summit but unless the
building blocks are clear between these
two countries
about an agreement there won't be an
agreement it'll be a failure
i think that's absolutely right it would
be a failure and
if i was sitting at the heart of british
government now and thank the lord i'm
not
uh what i would be doing is even now
starting to decide
what the out what the realistic outcome
we can expect from this conference
what will it be what will we be asking
of the americans what will
we be asking of the chinese what we'll
be asking of
to mention to other big polluters the eu
and what will be asking
of india and other medium-sized
polluters like turkey
and and iran and can we construct
a set of conclusions that stands a
chance of being accepted by
by the membership i would expect people
to be working on that
right now the other thing to bear in
mind is that we all say this is the
return of
multilateral diplomacy the kind of thing
that donald trump despised
well it is multilateral diplomacy but
it's kind of
bilateral diplomacy and national policy
in drag
it's not real multilateral negotiation
around a huge
table china the united states everybody
else has got to decide
how they see the progression of their
domestic economic development
and how this fits in to some kind of
environmental vision
so although we're being nasty to china
right now because of the uyghurs and
hong kong
and all that in the end it won't be that
that the size the chinese one way
or another uh to play nice in glasgow
it'll be a
hard headed calculation they will make
between making ourselves look better in
the world by
subscribing to climate change objectives
um and how do we see our economic
development
always remembering that the objectives
set in paris
five years ago were political and
non-binding aspirations and all the big
polluters have failed
to meet those targets which they signed
up for
uh five and a half years ago
christopher kt bowles we'll leave it
there thanks for being with us on
spectator tv but we stick with the
subject
of climate change i'm joined now by
stanley johnson former mep
vocal green campaigner and the
international ambassador for the
conservative environment network of
course the father of the prime minister
too
may be one of the pressures on the prime
minister to go more green
over the years sandy johnson welcome to
uh spectator
tv i want to concentrate on
what will the cost be of getting to net
zero emissions by 2050 which is the
explicit
uh aim of the british government
are you able to tell us what the net
cost will be
by 2050. well i can give you some
conclusions if you like of what the the
global commission
on the economy and climate um concluded
on this and that was set up by
by seven countries and that included
that included the united kingdom and
they
they concluded that the transitioning
to a low-carbon sustainable growth
path could deliver a direct economic
windfall of
26 trillion us dollars
and create over 75 million new jobs by
2030
compared with business as usual so
that's the adventure then the energy
transition
commission showed that decarbonizing
hard to abate sectors such as steel
aluminium
cement and heavy transport is
technically feasible
by 2050 with the technology that already
exists
and the total cost to the global economy
would be less than
0.5 percent of gdp by
mid-century and could be reduced even
further i think the point i want to make
andrew is that this is really a
no-brainer
in terms of the amount of money it costs
when you consider
that this country alone has mobilized i
this is is it is it 400
400 billion um pounds for kovid
well what was paris asking a few years
ago paris asking
was asking for 100 billion
a year uh to be mobilized well i think
you can see therefore
that the idea that we are unable to
afford
to deal with with climate change is
totally ridiculous this is
an existential issue far more important
than kobe devil was infinitely more
important
well the british committee on climate
change
which is full of like-minded people like
yourself
it says that it's going to cost we will
need to spend 50
billion pounds a year until 2050
that accumulates to 1.5 trillion
pounds if it's a no-brainer that we
should be doing that
why is the government know when you're
spending that kind of money
well partly because of the free rider
the free rider issue this does need to
be seen a little bit
in the context of a global
agreement or at least as as um
christopher was saying a moment ago in
the context of agreement between the
major
the major parties involved it's that's
why glasgow is important
because what went wrong at paris what
went wrong at paris was not the targets
they set
the 1.5 or the two but what has gone
wrong
is that none of the so-called national
determined contributions
when you add them all up together they
simply don't get us on track for that
right but i'm thinking with the britain
at the moment okay the moment
and the government's own climate change
committee says 50 billion a year
far from spending anything like that now
in fact it's cutting back it's only
recently that the government
scrapped the green home grants that
allowed retrofitting homes
to make them more energy efficient
scrapped the public accounts committee
concluded that the government quote
lacks a plan
to reach its net zero by 2050
target so we've got the rhetoric i don't
see any sign of the money being spent
or the plan to achieve it well i think
the uh
the the the carbon the carbon
carbon committee the thing which lord
demon shares
has indeed made those made those
criticisms the key issue is actually
not necessarily what happens in 2050 the
key issue may be what happens in 2030
now
um the government has committed itself
to get a substantial reduction i think
it's a
a 60 reduction by 2030
on the so-called 1990 targets which is
effectively saying more or less
halfway where we have to be halfway
there now on the money point
that money doesn't all have to be spent
by the government and
let's be clear about that i mean the
mobilization of the private sector here
is tremendously important and and it is
going
it is going on i mean mark carney has
been established as the private
advisor to the president of the climate
change
conference alok sharma and i imagine
he's doing a pretty good job
about mobilizing private finance and i
have certainly attended meetings
recently
where bankers are beginning to realize
that if they fail
to support as it were climate friendly
projects
or if they if they go even further in
the other direction
and support non-friendly products they
could get into trouble they could even
be sued
so we are i think going to move in the
right direction here well
we move in the right direction in terms
of broad brush promises but it's the
actual
policies and money required to deliver
that i'm still trying to find for
example
another broad bus promise is the pledge
by the government to protect
30 percent of uk land and sea
for conservation can you point to any
action that's been taken to implement
that
yeah let's get let's get on to this um
for a second
on the um on the on this issue of
targets if i could just step back
for one moment um on the target thing i
would agree with you there is a problem
the environment bill going through
parliament at the moment does not
include
the kind of definitive targets which
you've just
referred to the prime minister has on
several occasions including on
international meetings said yes we are
committed
to the 30 target by 1930 for marine and
terrestrial
systems in terms of protection now in
terms of marine
systems it is perfectly possible that we
can be
there because we can include the
overseas territories
as far as land is concerned yes it does
mean
that there's a big need for a further
big push
on protected areas i came into this
whole business years and years and years
ago one of the things i did
most recently was in the european
commission to write the habitats
directive
and the habitat directive has led to
something like 18
of the land of this country but my
question was to to
to get you to point to what action has
been taken to meet this pledge
well what action has been taken is we
have for example
transferred the all the sites under
under the habitat
for inter into uk law and we have a set
of
of uh sites of special scientific
scientific interests we have the
national park system
we are not far off the 30 percent figure
of as far as terrestrial sites are
concerned that is the fact andrew you
can
you can verify it we're not far off and
i think there will be pressure
on the government in this next few weeks
as the environment bill comes back to
parliament
to put these targets actually in law
in the environment bill do you think
that the politicians and campaigners
like yourself are being
honest with the british people i mean
for example
do you think that the british people are
aware that to meet this target
of net zero by 2050 that every
gas boiler every gas heater on the land
will have to be replaced
yes i think the bridge people are
becoming increasingly
aware of that and i think they're
becoming increasingly aware that the
technologies
exist for those transitions transitions
to be achieved
honestly i think we have we're in a
different we are in a different area now
and of course the important thing is for
people to realize
that it's not just 2050 we've got to
look at is also
2030 we've got to look at so i think
it's gonna i think we are going to get
that but
someone was right when they said a lot
of this will of course depend on
on political will i mean the government
has a majority at the moment and
can carry things through we need to be
sure it continues to do that
over a period of years what's the
technology that will replace the gas
boiler
well one of them is the hydrogen-based
technology another one is that is the
ground heat pump
ground heat pumps struggle in extremes
of temperature either lots of heat or
lots of cold
and hydrogen is very expensive and on a
mass scale as yet untested
well i'm not saying they're not going to
be technological problems there are but
you've got people out there
who are ready to put private capital
have you been honest with the british
people that this is what they'll have to
do
because when i speak to people about
this not politicians were just
just voters they had no idea that the
gas boiler was going to be replaced
well i think these are messages
therefore which need to be
need to be get need to be got across and
and i think they will be got across the
transformations are beginning to happen
in the transport sector i think we are
seeing a shift now to
um electric vehicles the crucial
secretary of agriculture i think
will see a lot of transformations in
this country i linked this
also to the biodiversity issue which has
come up several times in the
conversation
that by the way and you said it before
is one of the government's twin
challenges
climate change yes and biodiversity yes
the transformations in agriculture are
tremendously important and they have to
happen
you you've been happy to be associated
with extinction or rebellion you said
you were
one of the happy to be i caught you an
uncooperative crusty
on such matters roger hallam one of the
founders of extinction rebellion
has said that climate change will kill
six
billion people in the decades ahead
and that that was caught based on hard
science
do you know what hard science that was
based on
i personally don't know what hard
science that was based on
but but what i will say is that it is
perfectly clear
that the impact of climate change over
the next
decades is going to be very very severe
not just in economic terms
but also in terms of of mortality
and morbidity and so on and so forth
like that so i mean for from my
for my money the extinction rebellion
are completely right
when they point out these sorts of
things i i quite i don't know about the
six billion
the six billion figure well either is
right or is wrong
i'm sorry right and we don't know the
hard signs no i'm so sorry
it can't be important no no of course
you can if you're looking to the future
and you're making predictions of the
future
nobody knows whether those predictions
are right or wrong that's that's not
hard science
right okay um
let me just uh ask you about china which
we were talking about earlier um
what what do we do if china says
okay we're we're we'll cooperate with
you
on global policies to combat climate
change
but stop lecturing as about human rights
we have
our response we have there's no there's
no issue
in my mind we absolutely have to work
with
china on climate change and on on
biodiversity these are existential
issues of
huge importance and it is not a it is
not within our
our power i think uh serious uh
serious players in public policy to say
we will not work
with china as we as we try and face the
climate change and biodiversity issues
that doesn't mean to say so we sacrifice
the the uyghurs for cooperation on
climate change
well i'm not going to say that i'm not
going to say anybody needs to be
sacrificed
what i will say what i will say is the
chinese have to realize
i'm sure they do realize that the
evolution of policy
is not going to to go in their direction
um
they cannot in the end maintain ezra the
line they are taking
on weakest i'm sure of that but i don't
think you can say it's the question of
trading one for the other
but the chinese may well say that i
will say that you need our help to meet
the climate change targets
without us you can't do it um but we're
not going to help
if you keep on complaining about what's
happened happening to the uyghurs
hong kong and our build up in
military in off the coast of taiwan
or you're calling what's happening to
the weakest genocide you do all that
we're not helping and by the way we're
still building more coal fire stations
than the rest of the world put together
well
on your last point you were right i
think it's tremendously unlikely
that the chinese are going to say we
won't cooperate on climate change unless
you pipe down
about the weakest and so on i simply
cannot see that
because if there's one country which
also needs progress on climate change
as much if not more than any other
country it is china
herself this is this is the point and in
fact we have seen recently the chinese
have said we will try and get
to net zero by 2060 with any luck
they'll come in and uh 2050 and with any
luck we'll see some substantial
commitments
for for peaking uh by 2030.
so why is it's not a trade-off why would
they be able to come in
at 2050 uh even 2060
when they are massively increasing their
own coal-fired capacity
massively increasing it plus paying
for and building other coal fire
stations
all around the pacific rim they are
doing that now
their co2 emissions in the second half
of last year
sword why would you believe them
that they have any intention of meeting
these commitments
when you look at what they're doing well
this is what diplomacy is all about
this is presumably what mr kerry is
going to be saying to them
in them in beijing this week i couldn't
agree with you more
this has to be the basis on which we
work
they have to to do what they can do and
what they will do and then they have to
go beyond that
and do it yeah that's what i mean i
couldn't agree more
what china does is going to be vastly
important the good news is that we have
a difference now in the
in the american position which is going
to help i think enormously
all right uh stanley johnson thank you
for being on spectator tv
thank you b for being with us today
if you enjoy what we do here at
spectator tv why not take out a
subscription to the spectator magazine
it's the fastest growing current affairs
publication in europe within its pages
and on our website you can read all your
favorite spectator
tv contributors we'll even throw in a
20-pound amazon gift voucher
all for free if you sign up at spectator
dot co dot uk
tv offer or you can just google
spectator tv
and you'll see a subscription offer of
12 issues for 12 pounds
and that free 20 20-pound amazon voucher
you can do the arithmetic your quids in
if you take that offer
now so far on this edition of spectator
tv we've not
mentioned covered or at least covered it
but i'm afraid we are going to now uh
this week boris johnson said that the
fall in cases and hospitalizations
uh and deaths was not a result of the
vaccine roll out
uh i think many people will be surprised
by that
but regardless of what boris the
epidemiologist thinks
what is the data show let's go to kate
andrews now our economics editor and
editor
of our lunchtime briefing email with the
latest data from the spectators
covet data hub thanks andrew yes
very strange comments from the prime
minister this week putting essentially
all the focus on lockdowns
for the progress we've made in tackling
the virus so far instead of vaccines
so let's have a quick look at the data
and where we are now before we dig into
that
as you can see from this first slide
infections are down 97
from the peak of the most recent wave
here we're looking at the seven day
rolling average and current infection
rates are roughly around where they were
at the very start of september last year
on this next slide those being admitted
to hospital for covet are down 96
from the january peak also hovering
around early september
rates and deaths down a staggering 98
from the peak london has reported zero
cova deaths
for several days this month including
twice this week
now that can always be revised upwards
so we take it with a pinch of salt
but it certainly enhances the narrative
that the virus is really on the retreat
so is this success story playing out
across europe the answer is sadly no
andrew
the grass i've shown reflect that the uk
has experienced one of the fastest falls
in case rates around the world and now
as you can see here currently has the
lowest
case rate in europe but other countries
like france are still struggling
to get their cases under control so if
you compare the uk here with the lowest
case rates to this next slide
where we have the highest rate for
vaccination in europe by a long way this
brings us on to the prime minister's
comments this week about what to credit
for our success in tackling kovid
this time around now the uk for months
this winter was in one of the strictest
lockdowns in the developed world and
no doubt that played a big role in
bringing numbers down
that's what lockdowns do they suppress
the virus but they can't eliminate it
that wasn't really the controversial
part of his comment it was the emphasis
he was putting on vaccines
not playing a crucial role in the story
so far
and they're comments that head of the
nhs sir simon stevens has countered
perhaps not intentionally but certainly
in effect by stating after the pm's
comments that quote vaccines are
successfully reducing hospitalizations
and deaths
amongst the cohorts that have had the
vaccine end quote
and those are of course the people who
are the most vulnerable because we've
prioritized the vaccine for the elderly
and those most vulnerable
um to having a severe reaction to this
virus in the first place
and the ons infection survey backs this
up
as you can see from this graph here it's
now estimated that roughly half of
britons have antibody prevalence
with one in two people in england
scotland wales and northern ireland
thought to have antibodies and crucially
it's people in the most elderly age
brackets
that have the most prevalence and this
is something that sir simon stevens was
also keen to highlight
saying quote data that we have analyzed
shows a 75
reduction in emergency covert
hospitalizations for the vaccine cohorts
and as more and more people are
vaccinated that effect will
widen and quote so what do we make of
this
to be honest it's very hard to
disentangle the lockdown effect and the
vaccine factor this time around
the odd thing wasn't that the pm was
giving credit to lockdown but that he
once again deliberately
was playing down the vaccines this isn't
a one-off
for about a month now this kind of
rhetoric has been on the rise
with lots of focus on vaccines not being
100
effective from both the pm and his
officials
now that is a true statement but still a
very strange one because nobody ever
ever thought we'd get a vaccine with 100
efficacy that the vaccines we're using
are as effective as they are based on
the data we currently have is really
nothing short
of a scientific miracle so the question
now
is why is there all this caution around
talking up
the vaccines what's behind this is there
real data-driven concern in downing
street
about the possibility of a new variant
that can undermine vaccines
is this an attempt to keep people
following the rules for a bit longer for
as long as possible really
as their older relatives are getting
that protection through the vaccine and
they're fearful that people might start
taking the rules and taking their life
into their own hands once again
well either way that's probably the
conversation and the honesty that the pm
should be having with the nation rather
than what we're getting now which is
quite a muddled rhetoric with the
vaccine which so far
is proving to be a big success story
back over to you andrew
thank you for that kate if you want to
sign up to kate's daily email just
google spectator
livestream briefing that's
spectator lunchtime briefing or if you
want to see the numbers for yourself
just visit spectator
dot co dot uk data now as the world
ventures back into some kind of
normality at least some parts
of the world vaccine passports have been
seen as the way forward by some
not so in the united states where
president biden has ruled them out at
least on a federal level
well to discuss this and what else is
happening in america i'm joined now by
professor
lawrence gauston from georgetown
university
in washington dc he runs the who's
center
on national and global health law
professor gosselin thank you for joining
us on
spectator tv before we get into the
vaccine passports could you give us just
an
overview of where america now is with
the pandemic
well you know there's good news and bad
um i think for the next
uh four to six weeks we're in a perilous
position
um because we've got you know enormous
pandemic fatigue governors are
starting up businesses and restaurants
people aren't wearing masks and we have
um
you know particularly um prevalent
variants particularly the one that was
originally found in the uk
which is causing surges in in certain
um parts of the united states uh
so we are in a perilous position and say
in the next month
but our vaccination campaign is going
extraordinarily well
um and i think most forecasts
are that um by this
summer um certainly by the autumn um
we are going to be pulling our way out
of this
so i think it's going to be slow and
steady and then ultimately
i think there'll be some dramatic
reductions
in particularly hospitalizations and
deaths because of the vaccine taking
hold
president biden has said that by the end
of may
um every american who wants a vaccine
can get one and i think that is
realistic
even with the johnson and johnson pause
i saw some overnight concern in michigan
and other parts of the upper midwest of
the variant there even despite quite a
high degree of vaccination taking place
uh something of a sort of a third wave
uh it was suggested we're not out of the
woods yet if that's happening
no we're not and that that's the fire i
was talking about
um and there are other places in the
united states i mean
really what we've learned from covid um
you know so
very clearly is is that you know it's
not so much as a wave but as a series of
forest fires and so
when when one when one pops out
um in one part of the united states or
the world
um and others are feeling you know quite
good about themselves and complacent
it always moves and you know i do expect
that to happen
you know in the next month um that the
united states as i say is going to be in
a perilous position in that month and we
really do need to be
very careful in terms of masking and
distancing before the vaccines
really really take hold but eventually
they will you know and i
i've actually seen this movie before um
with
other major health
health threats things like smallpox
polio even
measles and other childhood vaccinations
when you have an extraordinarily
good set of vaccines combined with high
population coverage
you really can make dramatic differences
and i think
we will over the medium to longer term
what role then do you think vaccine
passports would have in britain
other parts of europe there's quite a
matter of controversy
i'd like to divide it into two other
official
government vaccine passports is one
possibility which
you may need to cross borders or to get
into the country or
into another country and then and this
may be particularly relevant in america
because of your highly federalized
system
50 states each of which in some ways can
go their own way
on this do you envision a situation
where either businesses
or individual states will be demanding
some proof of vaccination
before saying you get into a restaurant
or into an office or whatever
yeah andrew you've you've actually put
your finger right on it you know there
are three possibilities you know one
is uh the federal government in the
united states
and as you said president biden has
ruled that out
and i think for political and legal
reasons
he may be right to do that although i do
have one criticism i can mention
then there'll be state governments which
really hold the major public health
powers
but most of the action is actually going
to be
at the private sector level and already
our equal employment opportunity
commission
which is a federal agency has said it's
entirely lawful for
businesses to require employees to show
proof of vaccination
as a condition of returning to work and
major colleges and universities
have um been announcing mandatory
vaccinations
georgetown just did it yesterday partly
on my advice
um so i think that we are going to see
this in the private sector let me just
mention
president biden's position um because
you know i while i agree the federal
government should not
mandate it i think it would just be a
huge backlash
and challenged in the courts but i
you know i do think that the federal
government should be providing national
scientific um uh guidance and technical
assistance
um to whatever state and private entity
that wishes to do it
otherwise we're going to get a patchwork
of you know
variable inconsistency just the way we
did with
testing and ventilators and masking and
a whole other
other things under under the trump
administration so i think it would be
wise to provide
federal guidance but not a federal
mandate
i'm interested that you think i i if i'm
a restaurant owner
and i'm allowed now to serve meals
indoors
uh that if i say but to do that i want
to see your
vaccine passport that that i won't be
litigated to hell i mean in the most
litigious country in the world i think
you've got more lawyers in the rest of
the world put together
i mean this is not a dripping roast for
lawyers
it is and no matter what you know if
you've got something that's got a toxic
combination of being
highly controversial and polite and
political
and also you've got a lot of lawyers
running around you will get litigation
you know certainly i think one thing is
absolutely clear that businesses
can require proof of vaccination of
their employees
i think you know we've had federal
guidance on that it already happens
um you know with hospitals on flu at
universities with various
uh uh vaccination requirements at
schools
i think we you know we are going to see
um these this kind of thing happening
for customers i also think it will
happen it's a little bit of a gray zone
but i don't think much i mean there's
this
you'll see signs on a lot of american
shops
you might even see them in the uk you
know no shirt
no shoes no service you actually
absolutely are allowed to set standards
up about your hygiene and health and
safety standards for those who you serve
we already require masks you know
even in states that don't mandate masks
businesses say you know you can't shop
here or you can't dine here
unless you put on a mask same thing with
a vaccine
you know a vaccine gives you a certain
cushion of safety and i think it's in
the economic
interests of businesses
um to make their employees and their
customers
feel safe and i don't think there's
anything
wrong with that you know there's this
huge argument in the united states i'm
sure there is in the uk i
lived there for 15 years and my wife's
from the lake district
so i know it really well you know that
you know
that somehow requiring a vaccine or
proof of vaccination as a condition of
services a violation of my
autonomy or my liberty or my rights
everybody has the right to make any
decision about their own health and
safety but they
don't have the right to go without a
vaccine or without a mask in a crowded
place
and expose someone else to an infectious
disease that could kill them that's not
your right
the biggest issue here is equity and
fairness
we have to make sure that no one is left
behind and that everyone who wants a
vaccine
can get a vaccine that's why i suggest
it to georgetown
and to other universities you know don't
have a vaccine mandate unless you can
actually provide a vaccine
for anyone who doesn't have it and we
will do that
and just for clarification what you
couldn't do in america
an individual state couldn't say you
can't come into this state unless you've
got a vaccine passport because
the the borders between states are
totally porous so they couldn't operate
in that way
i'm right in thinking well yeah i'd like
to as well but we
you know what was what was standard
thought um
just as you thought andrew became
blurred during the pandemic and so
many states um put um testing
requirements on coming into their states
you know when when new york had its
flare-up
florida prevented new york residents and
made them show
testing uh requirements and then when
florida
flared up new york did and it went on
and on you know most states did that in
one form or another
but normally what that does is say you
know unless you show me a negative test
or a negative
um or or that you've been vaccinated
we'll quarantine you when you come in um
but you know it's
technically you're absolutely right as a
constitutional matter you
you states are not allowed to impede
travel from one state to another that's
a federal responsibility
you sounded that although there may be
some rough times uh
in the the spring and summer months
ahead
that you sounded quite optimistic about
america's position overall
as we approached the end of this year
did did i pick that up correctly
you did you know and i'm and and those
who followed
my what i've said publicly um
i i've always been um you know very
um dour and pessimistic about this
and you know you know when it when it
after it arose and wuhan
and came to europe and the us i said
this would take about
two years before we came out of it just
historically that's what pandemics are
like they have
two year cycles and we're in a period of
quite advanced science and people
thought that i was being
awfully pessimistic and i've been
pessimistic throughout but
uh one thing i do know that in the uk
europe the united states for some reason
we have the virus has been just too much
for us to handle
we either won't or can't change our
behavior
um the way that other countries have
been able to do
but one thing we're really good at
particularly in the uk in the us
is science and and vaccine development
and
deployment that's what's going to get us
out of this and so yes
um by the autumn and certainly by the
end of this year i
i think we are going to be approaching
we're not going to be completely normal
we will be
approaching more normalcy um we'll
probably still
quite a while be masking and distancing
but i do think we'll be
you know doing the things we really want
to do you know
hug our family and and and you know
recreate and shop and you know and and
see our football games
well that's a great note to end on
professor professor
lawrence gosten thank you very much for
being with us
on spectator tv that's it for this week
and thanks to all of our guests and once
again to our very special sponsor
charles stanley
for sponsoring the week in 60 minutes
charles stanley
is one of the uk's leading wealth
management firms it's one of the oldest
firms
on the london stock exchange a final
reminder pick up that 20 pound
amazon voucher all yours for free if you
sign to
the up to the spectator at spectator
dot co dot uk slash tv offer or
make it easy just google spectator tv
and get that voucher get 12 weeks for 12
pounds
of the spectator as always send any
thoughts to
spectator tv spectator dot co dot uk
that's it for this week join us again
next week bye bye
[Music]
you